Speaker 1: Let's go to George from
Littleton. George, welcome to the show.
Speaker 2: Hey, David, thanks a lot.
Speaker 1: Thank you.
Speaker 2: It's not a quick kind of
thing I've been thinking about is
how do you combat the just the Trumpian way of
kind of talking like like I can tell you David
aliens this and the question that I just
say well, everyone's talking about it,
you know, just kind of that kind of way of
speaking or haven't you heard everyone's
talking about it and you're like, well, isn't
the news reporting on this? And it's just
kind of that same, you know, oh,
what? What? You can't trust the news.
Speaker 1: George. I'm not sure. Are you
saying what are good responses when people say,
yeah, yeah, I don't know. Everybody
says the election was stolen. Like,
how do you respond when someone goes?
Speaker 2: Everybody's saying it was funny that
like could tell you that. Well, it
means, you know, something just absurd,
like, aliens exist. And I just keep
repeating that same type of argument.
Speaker 1: Okay, you want to do, like, a role
play? We'll try it. You'll be the person with
the belief, and I'll kind of do it the way I would
handle it. Exactly. Okay. So, like, tell me, like
everybody says, we know the election was
stolen from Trump. Let's start there. Okay,
so give me that line and we'll go through it.
Speaker 2: Yeah. So. So. Well, the election was
stolen. You know, everyone. Everyone knows it.
Speaker 1: How do you know it?
George. How do you know? Why do you
believe the election was stolen?
Speaker 2: Oh, well, you know,
because everyone's talking about it.
It's been proven. There's there's you
know, all the all the facts are out there.
Speaker 1: Okay. Tell me, for
example, who's talking about it?
Speaker 2: Oh, Fox News. Yeah,
Fox News is reporting on it.
Speaker 1: And what did Fox News say?
Speaker 2:
There's just a lot of the, you
know, the the election, the, uh,
the integrity of it, the corruption.
Speaker 1: Mm hmm. And in which. In
which state did this happen? Where Trump actually
won, but the state was given to Biden. What's one
state that's an example of that?
Speaker 2: I think Georgia was
the biggest the biggest one.
Speaker 1: Okay. And how do you
know that Trump really won in Georgia?
Speaker 2: Yeah. There was just so much
election fraud. You can't trust it.
Speaker 1: Do you live in Georgia?
Speaker 2: Oh.
Speaker 1: So how do you know
that? That's what happened in Georgia.
Speaker 2: Oh, that that's what all
the news is reporting on it.
Speaker 1: Okay. And how did
they say that it was stolen? Was it people
filling in multiple ballots that someone had
something to do.
Speaker 2: With
the 4 million ballots they were bringing in the
truckloads of ballots and there was all kinds
of fraud. It just couldn't be trusted.
Speaker 1: Mm hmm. And how do you know
whether those reports are accurate?
Speaker 2: There's just enough people questioning
it that that it's hard to believe the results.
Speaker 1: When a lot of people question things.
Do you tend to assume that they're correct?
Speaker 2:
I mean, not necessarily they're correct,
but that it just raises enough questions
for me to do that. I would not believe it.
Speaker 1: A lot of people say that the vaccine
magnetized as you. Do you believe that?
Speaker 2: Now myself personally. Okay.
Speaker 1: A lot of people say the earth is flat.
Do you believe that? So. So a lot of people often
say lots of things and you don't believe them. Why
do you think that this time the people are right,
but in all those other cases, they're wrong.
Speaker 2: Yeah. I think, you know,
just can choose I guess. Well but I think.
Speaker 1: Anyway, I mean it, it's actually
harder with someone who I know doesn't believe
the stuff, but you get the point. Like eventually
we would get to hopefully just getting them
to, to realize that, that, that their opinion
is not really based on anything is that, I
mean, that's the idea I'm trying to give you.
Speaker 2: Yeah. Yeah. That, that definitely,
definitely helps when, when you break it down
that way. Yeah. Just start asking for more of the.
Speaker 1: I mean ultimately it's a better thing
than just beating them over the head and
screaming at them. So that's that's my
definitely. All right, George, thank
you for the call. Appreciate it.
Speaker 2: Thanks, David.
Speaker 1: All right. Take care. There's George
from Littleton, trying to do the tough work,
that's for sure. That is absolutely for sure.